une chanson très bien très bien
bon ben moi maintenant je vais vous
chanter quant au caire de la lune
bon au clair de la lune
mon ami piero ignazi me tue organisé un
concours de chant ouais et alors
j'aurais dû m'arrêter y participer
voyons ah non mais on ne reçoit ici que
les professionnels de l'art lyrique
monsieur valéry et à ton avis je ne suis
qu'un amateur
enfin dites moi monsieur du sénat ba oui
vous avez des relations
oui est ce que vous le connaissez l'ami
pierrot l'ami pierrot l'amepi reçues et
de la chanson a bien évidemment en
casimir sur le connaissent un garçon
très sympathique
je connais aussi son ami colombine elle
est très très joli t orange j'aimais
tellement les rencontrer malheureusement
pour toi casey mears est totalement
impossible sont des personnages
imaginaires que l'on voyait dans des
théâtres il ya aux quelques siècles et c
c'est beaucoup un siècle
oui un siècle est une période de cent
années
oh là là je ne sais même pas si je sais
compter jusqu'à 100 regrette pour toi
kazemi
mais dites moi monsieur du cinéma at il
encore c'est pierrot et colombine sont
imaginaires oui il suffit donc de les
imaginer mais ce que tu dis là casimir
est tout à fait intelligent écoute tu va
m'attendre dans le petit voix
je crois que je peux faire quelque chose
pour toi oh merci de rien à tout à
l'heure
tout à l'heure au caire dans la lune
om-anigo prête moi ta plume pour mes
très chers amis il faut que tout le
monde que vous mettiez que vous
arrive-t-il
figurez-vous que casimir voudrais
rencontrer pierrot et colombine pas très
bien ce que nous pouvons faire non
monsieur
[Musique]
quel américain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu es très jolie comme ça julie et ce
costume te va ravir
toi aussi tu es très réussi attention
j'aperçois casimir et monsieur du snop
qui arrive n'oublie pas tu m'appelles
pierrot entendez pierrot et toi tu
m'appelles colombine souviens toi
nous sommes des personnages naïfs
pauvres et poète d'accord que l'on
devine les émirs je te présente
mademoiselle colombie enchanté monsieur
casimir tout le plaisir est pour moi
mademoiselle mandarine colombine
et voici mon ami pierrot heureux de vous
connaître quasi mais j'imaginais plus
bronzés c'est que je bronze pour clair
de la lune
pierrot et moi allions faire un pique
nique
voulez-vous vous joindre à nous à
mettrait volontiers demoiselle colombine
je m'assiérai par terre ça sera plus
champêtre moi je préfère rester debout
comme ça je mange plus vite et davantage
[Musique]
et bien bon appétit à tous tu as le menu
pierrot certainement joli menu
entrées au choix un rayon de soleil ou
un rayon de lune
je prendrais volontiers un rayon de
soleil et voici que l'on bien j'étais
lissieu dorées à point
quant à moi je prendrais bien un peu des
taux c'est beaucoup voilà
l'avers et vous casimir mois en d2
également mais beaucoup avec du sel et
du poivre
[Musique]
et moi je prends un rayon de plats du
jour quelques vers de poésie
et
ou quelle fraîcheur
c'est un véritable enchantement
oui mais c'est pas très nourrissant
fromage une révérence de golog il nous
si j'osais gens dans ma vraie bien une
deuxième
voilà monsieur d'islam
[Musique]
dessert un jeu de mots délicat
quel régal à c'est comme ça que je
comprend un repas fin moi je n'ai rien
compris du tout cas fait un petit somme
[Musique]
les reposer son voyage elle ils sont
très sympathiques
oui si tu veux on leur demandera de
revenir
je ne pense pas que ce soit nécessaire
ah bon que veux tu dire eh bien les les
personnages imaginaires sont sont très
charmant mais mais leur passion commune
tout à fait imaginaire et pour moi il
n'y a rien de plus triste qu'on repart
fait avec un rayon de lune un poème ou
une révérence surtout quand on a un
énorme gloubiboulga qui vous attend sur
la table de votre cuisine
j'y pense un énorme reebok a dit avoir
monsieur les chnaoua
[Musique]